around the world now for for reasons his
family would not have wanted but they're
very grateful i think for the fact that
the world is paying attention
about the the other key character then
uh derek chauvin
18 years at minneapolis police
department what do we know about him
not a great deal in terms of his his
life story you're right he's a veteran
officer he was the most senior officer
there on that
uh on that day may the 25th last year
in fact he had trained at least one of
the other officers who was
there with him uh during that that
interaction
uh with um with george floyd we barely
heard his voice during the trial of
course he
as we know uh turned down the
opportunity to testify after talking to
his uh his
lawyer it was the only time really we
heard his voice in the court itself
we had a couple of snippets from his his
body camera that were that
was running on the day of george floyd's
death where he explained away
uh pretty short terms to uh to a
bystander and then to his supervisor
what had happened pretty much just
saying i had to hold him down he was
going crazy not much more than that
so we didn't hear at any point derek
chovin's
um side of the story if you like his
explanation for what happened other than
what his his lawyer eric nelson was
was laying out either in questioning
witnesses or in his closing arguments
it was only during eric nelson's closing
arguments actually that we saw
derek chovin's face in court for any
prolonged period of time he was allowed
to remove his mask
during that that that period only during
the rest of the trial apart from when
the odd witness had to identify that it
was him in court he was allowed to pull
his mask down so
the jury didn't get to see his face
didn't get to see much reaction
from him to anything that was being said
from the witness box he seemed to be
writing feverishly on a
yellow legal notepad throughout the
entirety of this
uh trial but we we didn't hear from him
uh
and and what his uh what his life uh
holds now of course is in
the hands of the jury but but his story
and the story of joy
george floyd inextricably linked
greg for the moment thank you let's
return to sally who is
outside the the courthouse explain
what's happening there sally and just
what i wanted to throw in and ask you
also
is is how much um there was a feeling
that derek chauvin had played up to the
crowd that were watching they talked
about
his pride and his ego uh as
as something that stopped him taking his
knee off george floyd's neck
yes certainly that's a a loss of what
the prosecution
talked about in court in their case uh
that
derek shaven was playing up to the crowd
that it was about his pride and his ego
uh well just to draw attention to what's
happening behind me
we've had an arrival in the last few
moments of courtney ross george floyd's
girlfriend who of course so bravely
uh gave testimony in court talking about
uh this couple's struggles with opioid
addiction
let's just see if we can listen in uh
she's appeared with a woman
called tashiro garaway
out of st paul police august 19 2009
since then i've been working very hard
to bring the families together
to be the support that i did not have i
have been harassed followed
um they've sat outside my home because
i'm fighting for justice
for justin and all stolen lives i
believe
that george floyd justin triden cordell
handy marcus golden demetrius hill
uh travis jordan uh all of the bananas
[Music]
i'm not sure if you can hear the order
audio of that anna but
uh who we're hearing from at the moment
is a woman called
tashira garaway and now she represents a
group called family supporting
families against police violence and
she's appeared
just outside court along with george
floyd's girlfriend courtney ross in the
last few moments now
i spoke to courtney ross a few days ago
she told me that she not only of course
lost her boyfriend george floyd
last year in such horrific circumstances
but a little over a week ago a 20 year
old black man dante wright was also shot
by police and died here in minneapolis
10 miles away from where we're standing
now and she knew
dante wright as well by an extraordinary
twist of fate courtney ross has found
her
self in the middle of two very similar
stories that have been playing out here
in minneapolis and that shooting of
dante wright of course inflaming
emotions and tensions here in the city
which has been described as a tinderbox
and certainly
it does feel like that it's been very
tense here
not just in recent weeks during course
of this trial but for months now
ever since the killing of george floyd
and we've seen nightly unrest
since the shooting of dante wright a
little over a week ago and courtney ross
george floyd's girlfriend who's just
arrived here outside court
as we await verdict has found herself in
the center
of these two very tragic stories
that that is quite extraordinary isn't
it sally um talk me through the decision
to televise the court proceedings
obviously covid
restricts the numbers of people who can
be in courthouses
um generally has it felt it was the
right decision
certainly with the pandemic it was the
right decision because there's been very
very few people allowed in court but
also due to the public
interest in this case the judge made the
decision
uh to have this trial televised the
first full criminal trial to be
televised in the state of minnesota due
to the public interest that's been
followed around the world and now
we can have a listen in uh to courtney
ross uh
and to shira garraway oh the police
federation is just full of racist people
that's right
the racism is so real here the racism in
minnesota is so real
this is not minnesota this is
mississippi
mississippi emma till's family
looked at the pictures of the father of
my son and said that looks like
emma teal the way they beat him and
killed him and threw him in a dumpster
this place is treacherous it's racist
and it's time to be
exposed
all summer we have been out here
protesting the families have been coming
together
protesters we've been coming together
supporting each other
coming in solidarity the families that
lost our loved ones
we're out here they leave us out here
just stranded they don't give us no
support the only reason george floyd is
getting support
the only reason well the passions as you
can see outside that courthouse is
the family gathered derek chauvin has
now arrived at the courthouse we are
told but let me bring
in jared carter professor at law at
vermont law school
how much are you how much is everybody
in america looking to this
uh this court verdict well this is a
major inflection point for not only the
law
but also i think united states society
writ large
and so i think we're all waiting all
across the country and quite frankly all
across the world to see
what does this jury do and we're going
to find out in the next hour
what happens uh whether or not the
defense is able to
uh successfully uh convince the jurors
it's got to be unanimous that the
defendant is not guilty or whether the
prosecution was successful
improving their case beyond a reasonable
doubt
and is it true that police officers
convicted for fatal shootings are the
exception not the rule i read in one
report that
since 2005 research has shown that only
35 officers have been convicted
of a crime related to an on duty fatal
shooting
no question about it is it is the
exception i think that's why this trial
was exceptional
not only because it was televised but
also because i think for the first time
we saw
law enforcement the chief chief of
police for the city
of minneapolis testify on behalf of the
prosecution
that simply does not happen uh in a
typical trial where a law enforcement
officer is accused of a crime and so i
think
for that reason this is a major
inflection point for the law
and for society and so guilty verdict
some suggestion could mark a turning
point in the fight against racial
equality in america is it really being
held up to deliver that
well look of course everybody under this
system is entitled to a defense
but there's no question if you look at
the data if you look at the statistics
that this is a problem in the united
states legal system and we're reflecting
on that we're looking at that's why we
see these protests
and so i think yes this is under a
microscope and yes
this will have a major impact going
forward if
indeed officer chauvin is convicted of
the crime
or the three crimes and the crucial
thing for the prosecution
is that time nine minutes 29 seconds
uh that derek shauvin's knee was on
george floyd's neck
even when he went limp um is there any
way past that for the jury
well look i think not only is it that
nine minutes and some odd seconds
but but let's be honest the jury has
reached a verdict in a very short time
as well
and i think one always says don't try to
read the tea leaves
but the truth is uh i think the fact
that they've reached a verdict this
quickly certainly indicates to me
that they are unlikely to find the
defendant not guilty
certainly on all of the charges uh so i
think it's
it's going to be interesting and we're
going to find out in an hour
and it's going to have major impacts on
the law and society in the united states
why so many charges and can you be found
guilty of all of them
certainly uh you can be found guilty of
all of them all of them
are different crimes and require
different burdens of proof
uh and so it's very typical for a
prosecution to bring multiple charges
for the same
acts and it's entirely possible that
chauvin could be found guilty of all
three
or just one or of course found not
guilty of them as well
but it's not uncommon for it to play out
this way how might this change
policing in america if it's not too big
a question well it's a big question it's
it's the 10 million dollar question
uh and i think the answer is it'll have
a major impact
because this has been under a microscope
because people are paying attention
if he is indeed convicted i think it
starts to change the way things are done
and it broadens that conversation that's
already happening about policing in the
united states
and yet again dante wright another
young man whose life has been lost um
why does this keep happening
well i think the part of it is the law
part of it is society there's no
question that there is systemic racism
in the united states
and we've got to confront that
unfortunately the courts are
ill-equipped i think to confront that
broadly
but this is an important milestone
supporting marker
from purely a legal perspective
nonetheless
this is a pandemic this is a crisis in
the united states
that we need to confront it's going to
have to happen community by community
legislature by legislature and in the
halls of congress
if we're going to get past this i've got
faith that we can today we're going to
see what
12 jurors in minneapolis minnesota thing
and what do
do people feel um the public communities
are they generally supportive
of police officers facing charges in
cases like this
well i think that just as with so many
issues in the united states there's
tremendous division
tremendous anxiety but i think here's
what i would say i think
the vast majority of american citizens
american residents
believe that justice must be done
certainly in a fair and equitable way
and everybody has the right to a full
and complete defense and is presumed
innocent under the constitution until
proven guilty
but if a jury returns a verdict of
guilty i think the american people will
respect that
based on a respect for the rule of law
and we'll move forward
into dealing with what are i think
admittedly
systemic issues of racism that still
exist in this country that we need to
confront
well good to hear your thoughts i'll let
you get back and back to the television
i know you want to hear this
jared carter professor of law at vermont
law school thank you let's return to
sally
give me a few minutes
yes we're just still awaiting a reaction
from the family of course and of course
the verdict itself but let me just
introduce to shira garaway who
represents
uh families against uh police violence
yes
uh tashira you've just arrived with
george floyd's girlfriend courtney ross
uh tell me how you're feeling right now
how has caught me feeling
courtney called me and asked me would i
come down here with her this evening
because she i have i am the fiancee of
justin tygan
who was brutally beat to death by the st
paul police
and thrown inside of a trash dumpster
august 19 2009
and so she called me this evening and
said to cher i really want you to be
with me when the verdict is read
she knows that i've walked this walk for
11 years now
so she just wants me to be with her
through this
um and so uh because justin was murdered
i know the feeling and i just
wanted to be here to support her in a
way that i didn't have when they
murdered justin 11 years ago
but i want you guys to know that there's
been over 470 murders at the hands of
police here in the state of minnesota
only one man being held shot accountable
and that's a minority man that killed a
white woman
and now is the time to change that we
need a guilty verdict for george floyd
but there's a lot of anxiety
fear of the families are re-traumatized
and we're hurting right now but um again
i am the founder of family supportive
families against police violence you can
find us online
but our families are together and
studying unity today and
of course there's been the killing of uh
dante wright as well yeah
we're his family as well around 10 miles
away from here
you say you work with his family as well
how are they and
what's how's that change the atmosphere
here in minneapolis
i think it made it i think it made it
even more upset for people people are
even more upset
because while we're waiting for george
floyd trial they can't even stop killing
other black men in the meantime
they just keep killing us it's a racist
place and this place needs to be under
federal investigation
and what would a guilty verdict mean for
this community a guilty verdict would
mean that they finally in history for
once in their lives did the right thing
like they were supposed to do for all
the rest of the hundreds of murders
they finally did the right thing and we
want justice for the rest of these
families as well
thank you very much indeed for speaking
to me thank you
there is certainly a very tense
atmosphere down here
and an absolute melee as you can imagine
it's not just
the entire american media who's been
here in minneapolis
uh during the course of this trial for
the world media
as well as we anticipate uh this verdict
which we're expecting in around half an
hour uh from now and there is certainly
i would say cautious optimism here that
this community
may get the guilty verdict that so many
of them have been seeking
uh given the jury have come back so
quickly
with a verdict cindy then the professor
of law we were just speaking to
had the same thought as well sally back
with you in just a moment let's go to
greg milam let's just talk about the
defense then greg obviously they did not
present as much evidence as the
as the prosecution um but they put it to
the jury
that there were other complicating
factors in the death of george floyd
tell us more
yeah that's right um there were only two
days of um
of the defense case actually compared to
ten days of the prosecution
and during that they called a couple of
expert witnesses one on use of force one
on
uh the possible cause of death a medical
witness uh
with the intent of putting them
what they focused on was that the heart
disease that george floyd undoubtedly
suffered from in his lifetime they
talked about his historic use of
opioids and other drugs and the fact
that he he may well have been using
drugs uh on that day suggesting that he
died of a drug overdose
on that day and not the the pressure on
of derek chauvin on his neck causing
asphyxia there were a couple of other
things they they mentioned through that
um
certainly the medical expert talking
about the carbon monoxide potentially
from the police car
uh where george floyd was restrained on
the ground next to that police car
he had a tumor in his um abdomen that
they they said could have caused a
release of adrenaline
and that might have caused a heart
attack so they cast around if you like
for various other causes other than the
one that um
the prosecution said was the real cause
and the one which the world watched on
those videos
of a police officer on his neck of
course that the defense
aim was to to create doubt they said
that there was no real proof
in the post-mortem examination that
asphyxia caused the death of george
floyd now
the medical expert said that there never
is any real proof of asphyxia
if that's how someone dies so if you
like it was left to the jury to
to to take from the prosecution and
defense what the key was there
greg for the moment thank you let's
return then to sally lockwood who's at
the court
i don't know maybe um
being like um someone who loves being a
mom and taking care of people
i feel like all i can do is just
worry about my my children and all my my
former students
and just check on them really through it
all because they're the ones that have
been
fighting so hard how are you feeling
that the jury have made a decision so
quickly
i i i feel like that's a positive um
and maybe i'm you know i could be being
my naive in the fact but
i feel like it's a positive i feel like
um it's
it's it was clear to them what happened
and they had no other choice but to
deliver a guilty verdict
sorry as the person closest to george as
a per as his girlfriend
so destroyed as you knew him what was it
like having to watch this
painful evidence through the course the
last few weeks um i
i did not i i stayed um away from any of
the visuals
uh i i can't my son has seen um
one moment of it in the past um a couple
weeks and that was enough um
to bring him to his knees so it was too
much
and how did can you just just also
remind people of your relationship with
dante wright he was killed yeah
oh my dante um i worked at edison with
dante
uh i i had a position as an educator
where i
got to work with a ton of students
and dante was one that of course i was
drawn to because he was a fun
silly boy i loved his energy
and the the loss of a student is um
it's very different than the loss of um
a loved one
and even in floyd's case because um
[Music]
you know dante's just 20. and he's to me
he's just like a boy you know he wasn't
people say a man in the media and to me
i just look at him
as a kid and um
and
i feel like his spirit like his spirit
is here
so i know i know he's here with us too
floyd's here dante's here what would it
be
for you and your family for george for
the city um
i think for the city it it would
mean a lot i think it's a it's a start
in bringing justice
to um so many of the families that
haven't received justice yet
and so that that's what it will begin to
bring and
it'll bring change for the future we're
already seeing like
how now you know for instance body cams
are coming out
within seconds or you know
um people are holding people accountable
now and not you know
sweeping things under the rug as per
usual
so we're making changes you're live on
sky news
what's your message to the world today
wow um
you know i try and think of what floyd
would say
he wouldn't believe all that
he you know
he he want everyone to come together
to love each other
floyd was very caring over vulnerable
people people that needed help um
some of the people that a lot of us um
turn away from in life
the ones that we don't want to see you
know they might be
a few blocks over excuse me a few blocks
over at salvation army over there
maybe over at psp
and um the ones that we don't want to
see floyd loved the most
and so um i think he would say you know
let's start taking care of each other a
little bit better
and love each other a little bit more
on that no i am going to take a break
y'all i cannot breathe so i'm just going
to walk away i'm so sorry
the world is with you as well thank you
thank you very much
that was uh courtney ross uh speaking to
us there george floyd's girlfriend
speaking very bravely before the world
media
on the edge of this historic ruling
which means
so much of course to her having lost her
boyfriend in the most horrific
circumstances last year
but as she so eloquently said there it
means a lot
to people here in minneapolis and around
the world she broke down there as she
said she's not she wasn't just
devastated seeing what happened
to her beloved floyd but she was also
devastated to see what happened to her
city in the wake
of his death as people took to the
streets in months of protests that
turned to riots
in the initial days because it took
several days for derek chovin
to be arrested and charged and as some
people have said to me in this community
he was arrested uh safely
unlike george floyd who he kept his knee
on
his neck for more than nine minutes as
we saw so many times
uh through the course of this trial uh
and we are expecting a ruling
very shortly from the jury who have
reached a verdict
to determine whether he will be
convicted of criminal charges
sally very very emotional there thank
you very much indeed as we heard from
courtney ross she hoped that it would be
clear to the jury what happened
she hoped that they would feel they had
no other choice but let's go back to
greg milam who joins us also minneapolis
if we look back to to may last year greg
why this case why those pictures why did
they resonate
around the world
well i think there's a there's a simple
reason is that there was a young woman
there
17 at the time called darnella fraser
who gave evidence in the trial you might
remember
she talked about how she sat up at night
apologizing to george floyd
for not doing more that the very fact
that she recorded
what the world saw is eight minutes and
46 seconds we now know that
that incident went on for longer and
posted that video on on social media
that night
so within 24 hours that the world had
seen within hours of
george floyd dying the world had seen
what had happened to him and how he died
and saw that image that of course is is
burnt into the consciousness of so many
people now of derek chovin kneeling on
his neck
you have to wonder if it hadn't been for
that video shared so widely on that
night
uh whether this case would have ended up
like
so many or whether we'd be here with
such attention on
uh on this case even the the police
chief
of minneapolis who testified during the
trial said that it was as he was
arriving at police headquarters that
night when the full
story of what had happened was was
starting to emerge started to hear about
that video so darnella fraser she's now
18 she's never talked
outside of the court about her decision
to record that night
uh she was standing next to her young
cousin i think it was if she'd gone to
the
to the shop where george floyd was uh to
buy to buy sweets in that shop
uh her role can't be overestimated
because that that video of course was
key in this case
and as we've seen with other uh
shootings that have happened when there
is that that video it's it's enormously
powerful
and plays a major part in in getting the
public's attention
and of course what it's meant as well is
that the police have had to be much more
uh transparent in
in many cases with their own video we
saw in this trial
the body camera footage from from the
cameras that all of those officers were
wearing including uh officer chauvin
that is that has built the picture of
that story but uh the incident with
dante wright that um that sally was just
talking about the police
released the body camera footage of that
incident uh the the incident in chicago
last week of the 13 year old
these these um these stories are now
being played out on video and the world
is seeing
uh that video and helping if you like
with the transparency but darnella
frazier's
decision to record and those eight
minutes 40 and 46 seconds that she
recorded
very significant uh critical to the
story of george floyd and derek chovin
greg we're still seeing the court seal
we are waiting obviously for judge peter
cahill to bring everybody back into
court from
hennepin county minnesota district court
uh let's just uh see the court seal
shall we just there we are we're just
waiting for the court proceedings and
everybody filing back in
no doubt to listen to the jury's verdict
after just over
10 hours but greg you were talking there
about the police chief who testified
against derek chauvin
but also from witnesses we heard that
the police
calling the police on the police and
this is real part two of the prosecution
case
yeah it wasn't and a real weight of
evidence from
as as you say the the police chief on
down the head of training
uh the head the expert in use of force
the longest serving officer in
minneapolis police force all appearing
for the prosecution against one of their
own officers uh but yet the the
bystanders who were there and and
uh they were described as a tableau of
humanity early on in this case there's a
still image of them all lined up along
the pavement there watching what was
going on and we heard many of them
calling on officer chauvin to to release
the pressure on
george floyd's neck to check his poles
all of the imploring that went on
but yeah donald williams who was a mixed
martial arts expert he worked with the
police
uh he said he called 9-1-1 after
witnessing what he saw
because he said he believed he witnessed
a murder the the
off-duty firefighter who was there as
well similarly who
tried to to render aid tried to to ask
if she could offer medical aid to george
floyd and was was pushed back she called
she called 9-1-1 as well to report what
she'd seen even
somebody working in the emergency call
center the dispatcher
who was watching just because she she
felt something was
something was wrong picked up one of the
images from a cctv camera across the
road
uh watched what was going on she thought
the picture had frozen because they were
on george floyd for so long
and called the supervisor to say i think
she said she
didn't want to be a snitch but she felt
something was wrong
they called the police on the police
which as was pointed out in some of the
closing arguments
is testimony to how people still feel
about the police in this city that they
feel they should be able to trust them
even though they were witnessing what
they were witnessing uh and believed it
was
uh wrong and the evidence of those
bystanders
all from very different backgrounds it
doesn't appear many of them knew each
other
uh was was critical in the early days of
this this prosecution case building that
picture
of just ordinary people who felt they
needed to do something but were
powerless because the people with power
were the ones carrying out uh the
incident that so bothered them
greg for the moment thank you very much
indeed i know we'll get more from you
and sally shortly
let's just bring in richard rose now
president of the atlanta naacp that's
the national association
for the advancement of colored people
welcome to you um we've just heard
heard from tashira garaway going into
the court with courtney ross the
girlfriend of
of george floyd saying that they feel
anxiety
fear the family feels traumatized ahead
of this verdict
how are you feeling well i'm on the edge
as much of america is as much as black
america is but also
many of humane americans across the
country are on edge uh wondering with
justice be served
or will there be a reason for people to
continue to protest you know over 100
days last summer
people hit the street and all across
this country to talk to uh protest
uh police abuse uh and police injustice
so
i'm hoping that verdict justice will be
served and then we can uh
that we will not have the uprising and
the unrest that we
experienced last year why is this case
so important what does it symbolize to
you and others
well frankly speaking it is a
continuation of what
black america knows has been going on uh
for
at least 155 years since since the civil
war
and the hope is that that uh
law enforcement in particular but all of
america will see
people of african descent as just human
and not as uh
not to be looked down upon and so we're
hoping that this
that if justice is served there can be
hope that america will finally
get to a point where it repudiates uh
racism in all forms
we've got live pictures um from above
the courthouse obviously people are
turning up there derek chauvin
is in we know richard crowds are
gathering no doubt
um many people very tense awaiting
these uh three or the verdict on these
three charges
and many people suggesting this is or it
could be
a watershed moment do you agree richard
rose
well i do i do this is uh justice on
trial justice
uh the trial has been and has been uh
broadcast for everybody to see it
we all saw the videos we saw again
videos from the police department so
we're just hopeful that america can
can finally get over its uh acceptance
of racism acceptance of the abuse of
people of color
and we can all move together toward our
future
toward our collective future if we
continue the division that we have
it can only continue to harm america's
progress
and in terms of the relations with the
police what needs to be done
uh in terms of training attitudes uh the
way they handle
situations like this and others you know
should there be a program put in place
now
um after this verdict well we believe
that
that america should restructure public
safety
which must include police but there are
many other professions that should be
involved
in police call in 911
psychiatrists psychologists
family experts social social workers
um right now we have three options for
our 9-1-1 emergency call
fire department emt's uh which is a
emergency medical technician and then
the police for all of us
these our police forces are not equipped
to deal with
all of the facets of of our society that
they might encount
encounter and i believe they must
elevate the requirements to become a
police officer
at least a college graduate and not just
a gde person who dropped out of high
school pass the test and not
all of a sudden they have life in depth
decision making authority we believe
that the entire
public safety processes and systems in
america
must be restructured must be changed
must must respond to some of the
atrocities that we have seen
very interesting richard rose thank you
very much indeed for your time there
president of the atlanta national
association for the advancement of
colored people thank you
well amidst that crowd as you can see
the sign there
justice for george floyd the world
is watching as you can see down in that
crowd
too is our correspondent sally lockwood
sally
yes anna hundreds if not thousands of
people have gathered outside the
courthouse since
uh that announcement came the jury have
reached a verdict in around just 11
hours of deliberation let me just show
you what's going on so we have
the world media gathered around someone
there who's giving a speech
about how much this means his name is
brian turling
do you know him yes and is he a local
actor
and can i just ask you what does this
mean for the community
today how significant is it it means
everything it's just a start but you
should be talking to people of color not
me
it means everything to this community
it's a beginning
you know it's a start you know it's
we've been marching for
a year almost and people are
highly emotional and it's not fair
you know there's only been one convicted
person in minnesota history of a police
shooting and it was of an affluent white
woman
by a black cop it's never happened so
this if it works it's because of our
protesting
thank you very much indeed for speaking
to us
as she was just saying that there has
only ever been one conviction
of a police officer in the state of
minnesota for the death
of a citizen and that was a black police
officer convicted for the death of a
white
woman a white police officer has never
ever been convicted
over the death of a black citizen here
in the state
of minnesota let me just show you what's
happening over this shoulder there's
hundreds if not thousands of people have
gathered
awaiting this verdict as you can see
it's very peaceful people waiting
uh with a sense of anticipation ahead of
the uh
verdict which we're expecting any moment
now and just beyond
uh this crowd you may be able to make
out members of the national guard
standing
on that balcony at the government center
which is
where the courtroom is now they've been
playing for weeks now during the course
of this trial and there's
up to 3 000 members of the national
guard who have been mobilized for this
trial because
there was a great deal of concern
that there could potentially be scenes
of unrest
uh following any acquittal
but there is a sense here among the
community that the fact that jory have
come back
so quickly they are hopeful it could be
the guilty verdict so many people here
are speaking
uh and we will wait to see how this big
crowd reacts many will be celebrating
if it's a guilty verdict and if it were
to be a not guilty verdict even on just
one
count certainly the mood could turn
[Applause]
sally thank you very much indeed and
certainly we know from your interview
with courtney ross the girlfriend of
george floyd that
she said he would want everyone to come
together he was very caring
let's start taking care of each other
perhaps that is a plea for calm
from her i know it's hard for you to
hear and one wonders actually if um
those shouts outside the court can be
heard inside can derek chauvin
hear those uh those chants uh from the
the passion that's in that crowd
greg milam let's go back to you derek
shoven worked for the minneapolis police
department for more than 18 years
within one week he was filmed kneeling
on george floyd's
neck he was fired and faced charges at
the time it's reported he had 18
prior complaints against him it is
interesting to see what will happen
now certainly some people feel the jury
have come back quickly
two days just over 10 hours three
charges under consideration
that's right in fact they went out
almost exactly 24 hours ago
to begin considering their verdict they
sat for four hours last night
eight o'clock in the evening they
decided to retire they're staying in a
hotel
designed to keep them away from the
media coverage any
possible interference any influence from
the coverage of this
uh trial and now another six hours today
and they have reached their their
verdict on those three charges second
and third degree murder
second degree manslaughter that first
charges is the most serious one
they had to decide whether what uh derek
chauvin did on may the 25th 2020 was a a
substantial causal factor
in the death of george floyd uh it
didn't have to be that he had the intent
to kill him
simply that he intended to do what he
was doing and that that led to george
floyd's death
and that it wasn't the reasonable uh
behavior of a reasonable
police officer now the law says that
there's a 40-year maximum sentence
for that uh charge of second-degree
murder the sentencing guidelines here in
minneapolis
suggest that someone without previous
convictions like derek chauvin
would maybe get 12 years in prison as a
sentence if
if convicted whether that will be enough
for those who've been demanding justice
we
we wait to see the sentencing will come
somewhere down the line from
that that verdict from the jury they
are now being brought back to court to
deliver uh that verdict and we wait
to hear what that is greg milam thank
you very much indeed so crowds have
gathered outside the courthouse
as you might expect there's been a delay
it takes time
to get both the defendant derek chauvin
to get the jurors
to get those who want to witness this
moment of history
back into court that verdict
it is 10 o'clock you're watching sky
news at 10 the jury has reached its
verdict at the murder trial
of the former police officer derek
chauvin in the death of george floyd the
black man who was pinned to the pavement
with a knee on his neck in a case that
set off
a furious re-examination of racism
and policing in the united states the
verdict arrived at
after about 10 hours of deliberations
over two days
is to be read out late afternoon
minneapolis time
in a city on edge against the
possibility of more
unrest like that which erupted last
spring
let's get the details then from our
correspondent greg marlum who is in
minneapolis
and derek chauvin greg facing three
charges
that's right yeah the jury uh was sent
out to consider uh chard of their
verdict on those those three charges
second-degree murder being
uh the most serious of those charges
that he committed a felony assault a
serious assault on george floyd
and that serious assault was a
substantial causal factor in george
floyd's
death of course the world has watched uh
how george floyd
how his life ended on may the 25th 2020
but it was for the jury to decide
whether what derek chauvin did was that
substantial causal factor
and whether his behavior in doing that
were the actions of a
a reasonable police officer two other
charges third degree murder
second degree manslaughter but the
prosecutor clearly prosecution clearly
wants guilty verdicts on all three of
those
very different charges but it's been in
the jury's hands
they asked no questions as jurors often
do during the course of their
deliberations we know they had access to
a
laptop they were able to watch the
evidence including that video
in the jury room as they carried out
their deliberations
uh but they didn't ask any questions
which suggests that they were
very clear in the direction that their
deliberations uh were going there's
quite a complex form that they're given
by the judge the judge's instructions a
series of questions in effect which
allow them to plot their way to a
verdict once they interpret the evidence
that they'd heard in in three weeks of
testimony
uh to get them to the answers and to
fill in that uh that verdict form
and they sent their message what about
an hour and a half ago now
uh to the uh to the the sheriff the
bailiff of the court that they'd reached
that verdict and were ready to come back
to court
the logistics of this trial this huge
security around the court building
uh covert restrictions as well meant
that uh it wasn't just simply a case of
ushering them back into court and
hearing that verdict
uh derek shover himself was allowed to
leave the building while they were
deliberating the the jury were in their
room
so it's taken some time to get everyone
back together for that
that verdict to be read but that's what
we are expecting once uh the judge peter
cahill
resumes the court we understand very
shortly absolutely we're still seeing
the seal of that courthouse as you said
hennepin county district judge peter
cahill presiding
over the trial we will wait to see what
happens
the verdict is due any minute now let's
go to sally lockwood then
who's outside amidst the crowds and
emotions running really high there sally
you've already spoken to
george floyd's girlfriend
[Music]
yes that's right rather extraordinary uh
scene
a few moments ago courtney ross george
boyd's girlfriend
who of course gave such emotional
testimony
in court as a prosecution witness during
this trial she arrived here outside the
courthouse
along with hundreds of other people as
you can see who've gathered
here in anticipation of this verdict and
she came down
and and spoke to me along with uh
some of the media about how she was
feeling uh
she was very emotional uh here's what
she said
um i i'm yeah i'm definitely overwhelmed
by all of this
um i'm i'm extremely hopeful that in a
matter of time it's going to come back
with a guilty verdict i just
i i don't know why i'm so sure and
i just i feel like it's about to happen
and um
maybe we can have a little bit of um
peace and and love going on for a second
in this city because there's been so
much
struggle for so long it's not just
you know it's not just our family it's
not just people who love floyd
it's my entire city that has been
suffering
and what's it been like finding yourself
in the centre of that
i don't know let's take you straight to
the courtroom
all right for the jury
all right please be seated
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict
[Applause]
members of the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court fourth judicial district
state of minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
verdict
count one court file number 27 cr2012646
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021 at 1
44 pm signed juror 4 person
juror number 19.
same caption verdict count 2. we the
during the above entitled matter as to
count
two third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19. same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter has to count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm jury four person zero
one nine members of the jury i'm now
going to ask you individually if these
are
your true and correct verdicts please
respond yes or no
juror number two are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number nine are these your true
and correct verdicts yes
juror number 19 are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number 27 are these your true and
correct verdicts
yes jury number 44
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 52
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 55 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 79 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 85 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 89 is this your
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes jury number 91 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 92 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes are these your verdicts will say one
so say you all
yes members of the jury i find that
the verdicts as read reflect the will of
the jury and will be filed accordingly
i have to thank you on behalf of the
people of the state of minnesota for not
only jury service
but heavy duty jury service what i'm
going to ask you to do now is
to follow the deputy back into your
usual room and i will join you in a few
minutes to answer
questions and to advise you further so
all rise for the jury
[Music]
all right be seated
with the guilty verdicts returned we're
going to have
blakely you may file a
written argument as to blakely factors
within one week
the court will issue findings on the
blakely factors the factual findings
one week after that we'll order a psi
immediately
returnable in four weeks and we will
also
have a briefing on after you get the psi
six weeks from now and then eight weeks
from now we will have sentencing
we'll get you the exact dates uh
in a scheduling order is there a motion
on behalf of the state
they would move to have the court revoke
the defendant's bail and remain him into
custody
pending sentence bail is revoked bond is
discharged
and the defendant is remanded to the
custody of the hennepin county sheriff
anything further all right thank you
derek chauvin rises his eyes had been
flicking he watched intently he is now
handcuffed and led away remanded into
custody
having been found guilty of three
charges
the 45 year old former police officer
had been charged with second degree
murder
found guilty third degree murder found
guilty
and second degree manslaughter all three
charges had required the jury to
conclude
that chauvin's actions were a
substantial causal factor
in george floyd's death and that his use
of force
was unreasonable second degree
intentional murder carries up to 40
years in prison this is unintentional
murder of course
third degree murder 25 years and second
degree manslaughter
10 years and outside this is the
reaction
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
[Applause]
i'm right in the middle of
apologies that was our correspondence
hallie lockwood's camera trying to get
reaction there but
as you can see head and hands tears of
joy
and relief they had expressed their
anxiety and their fear at this moment
but celebrations there black's lives
matter protesters
minneapolis residents who are clearly
deeply pleased to hear the result there
uh derek chavin found guilty on all
three charges that he faced
in the unintentional murder of george
floyd by putting his knee
on george floyd's neck for nine minutes
and 29 seconds
let's get the reaction then of our
correspondent greg milam greg
you see the reaction down there on the
ground but absolutely no reaction
as far as we could see from derek chovin
himself of course still wearing his mask
in court but
as those three verdicts were read by
judge peter cahill
reached by the jury after pretty pretty
short deliberation you've got to say
10 hours after a three-week trial the
judge
thanking them for what he called heavy
duty jury service
uh and we understand from from what was
said in court there that uh
derek chovin will be sentenced uh for
those
uh crimes in in eight weeks time and
then that moment that i'm sure will have
been
watched with interest by those um who
followed this trial which is derek
chauvin handcuffed
by the deputy inside caught there and
led away with his hands
behind his back of course we've seen so
much over the last few weeks of george
floyd handcuffed
behind his back uh with derek chauvin on
his on his knees so
uh i don't think a surprise really the
length of that deliberation
just those uh just those ten hours after
this trial
the fact that the weight of evidence
that the prosecution
put forward in this case did seem uh
overwhelming and as the prosecution said
the jury could see for themselves what
they saw is what they saw
in what happened on may the 25th 2020 we
are expecting to hear
from inside court shortly the attorney
general for minnesota keith ellison
and also george floyd's family inside
court we may hear more from them
later outside as well but yeah three
guilty verdicts
not really a surprise after what this
jury has sat through in the last three
weeks
and derek chovin now in custody what was
the prosecution
prosecution's case then greg apart from
see for yourself look at those pictures
and see for yourself what happened that
day well i think the fact the video that
we all saw within hours of
uh of george floyd's death that went
around the world and sparked all of that
anger in within hours of his death
was central to this uh case as well the
the very fact that
those images filmed by a young woman
darnell fraser she was 17
at the time had gone to that shop and
saw what was going on
the very fact that the jury could see
exactly what what everyone had seen
and then had that put into context um i
think was was critical
and then you add in the evidence of all
of those involved in the investigation
from the police chief of minneapolis
down
who appeared for the prosecution against
one of their own officers saying that
his actions weren't reasonable
that it was a use of force that wasn't
authorized all of the medical
professionals involved in the actual
investigation not just
expert witnesses the medical examiner
who ruled this a homicide
after carrying out the post-mortem
examination said that he died because of
common
cardiopulmonary arrest as a result
complicating that subduel and restraint
and neck
compression by the police for them the
evidence was very clear and i think we
saw that in their closing arguments
yesterday
that that whatever the doubts that the
defense raised about other possible
causes
for them they could see with their own
eyes what had happened and you could
hear some of the reaction on the streets
in
minneapolis around us they could see
with their own eyes
what happened to george floyd that day
and there were just two very simple
questions did derek chauvin cause his
death
and was what he was doing that day
reasonable for a police officer
and and they they they couldn't really
summon up anyone
certainly understood the minneapolis uh
police procedures
who could say that that action was was
reasonable and clearly the jury
were very clear and pretty quick in
coming to their conclusions as well
[Music]
greg thank you very much indeed we've
just had reaction from george floyd's
legal team
saying painfully earned justice has
arrived
for george floyd's family and the
community here in minneapolis
but today's verdict goes far beyond this
city and has significant implications
for the country and even the world
justice for black america
is justice for all of america this case
is a turning point in american history
for accountability of law enforcement
and sends a clear message we hope
is heard clearly in every city and every
state
we thank minnesota attorney general
keith ellenson and his team for their
fierce
dedication to justice for george but it
does not
end here we have not forgotten that the
other three officers who played their
own roles
in the death of george floyd must still
be held accountable
for their actions as well that is ben
trump civil rights attorney
acting on behalf of george floyd and his
family
let's listen again to that reaction
the people united
the people united
well there are hugs there are tears
there is passion
there is cheering there's applauding the
reaction as you can see of the crowd
to the uh guilty verdicts on three
charges
against derek chauvin who has been led
away in handcuffs
george floyd's lawyer's statement
continues today's verdict
is so critical in that it not only holds
derek chovan accountable
for his horrific actions but it
reinforces significant
police reforms underway in minneapolis
including use of force reporting a
requirement to keep body-worn cameras on
and a policy for officers to de-escalate
non-threatening encounters
by disengaging or walking away
we don't want another member to be added
to that
and we want to thank i wanted to say
this right now
this woman right here to shira some of
these black women
have been out here let's take you down
amidst the crowd now to our
correspondent sally lockwood sally
[Music]
okay hi anna if you can hear me
people have come out into the streets
here in downtown minneapolis
to celebrate people have stopped their
cars to get out
you might be able to hear the horns
and uh down here there's a crowd of
people who've gathered
outside the courthouse you could just
hear the noise the whole city
has erupted in what feels like
a community that is celebrating
all together and by such a stark
contrast look at the security that is
surrounding the courthouse here these
big metal fences
that have been here for weeks now with
the national guard
these military vehicles and members of
the national guard who've been
protecting the courthouse from rioters
and unrest but
so far certainly there seems to be
absolutely no need for that
as people have come out onto the streets
downtown here in minneapolis
to celebrate this historic verdict
it feels like a moment of history
undoubtedly the first time a white
police officer has ever been convicted
over the death of a black citizen here
in the state of minnesota
and it does feel like it might be a
first step towards some sort of healing
for this community let's listen
yes we lost connection didn't we to
sally but elsewhere in that crowd
as you can see uh people are savouring
this moment if you like they recognize
it's a moment
in history a hundred days of protest we
heard from one guest
earlier uh certainly protests there in
minneapolis
across america and eventually around the
world so let's bring in rachel pelosi
now former
u.s attorney for the district of
minnesota now teaches law at the
university of saint thomas
rachel what's your reaction
i'm so relieved because i thought the
evidence in this case was overwhelming
and in any other situation the defendant
would have pled
guilty would have would not have marched
to trial
i thought the defense's arguments in
this case were outlandish blaming the
victim
blaming the crowd denying the expertise
of world-renowned
doctors and scientists and i think that
we are all going to remember this day
for a long time to come as the day that
we rewrote
the state of racial relations and
african-american relationships with the
police in the united states
how did it come to this though rachel
that a police officer
who'd worked for the police department
for nearly 20 years
felt it was okay to have his knee on
somebody's neck until they went limp
well it came to this because police
officers have been doing this sort of
thing to people of color and in
particular to african-american men
and juries around this country have
acquitted them
of outrageous behavior today finally a
jury in minneapolis
has sent a message that this will no
longer be tolerated
at least in minneapolis i hope never
again anywhere in the united states
what now for derek chauvin we heard
sentencing in eight weeks time he's been
led away in handcuffs what what sentence
is he likely to face
well we know that the maximum sentence
he could face is 40 years based on his
sentencing guidelines he's
looking at possibly 12 and a half years
we also know that the state
believes there are aggravating factors
here including the abuse of his
authority
and the commission of this crime in
front of vulnerable people including
children
so i'm quite certain the the state will
ask for many more years than 12 and a
half
we're just looking at pictures of the
crowd amidst them the cameras moved off
now
we saw courtney ross the girlfriend of
george floyd
um you know very emotional as she was
heading into court
you know how many people will be
relieved as you are do you think by this
verdict
i hope that the family of george floyd
which
who all have been so courageous for the
last year
i hope they understand that midden death
has done
something that none of us could have
done in life
well we've had a statement from george
floyd's lawyers
they go on to say the impact of george
floyd's death on minneapolis is
impossible to explain
but today's verdict is an important step
towards healing
and rachel pelosi you know you obviously
clearly find it
extremely emotional as well what has
been the impact of his death on this
city
well i think for so many people of color
who have
on the one hand good experiences with
law enforcement who are
appropriate and understand their role
but on the other hand really unfortunate
experiences with constant profiling that
a message
needed to be sent that we understand
that law enforcement have a difficult
job
but no one should die for a 20
counterfeit bill no one should die
for an air freshener hanging in his car
no one should die for expired
license tabs and we need the police to
understand that we need law enforcement
to respect
the sanctity of life just as we respect
the authority of their badge
and i hope that this is a turning point
for the police
to interact in more healthy ways with
the community
well indeed the the lawyer statement
does say what officers need to do is to
de-escalate
non-threatening encounters by
disengaging
or walking away how is that achieved
what needs to happen now
well at a minimum use of force policies
need to be changed so
uh kneeling on on a person's neck is
completely unacceptable it was a relief
to me to see that that practice was
banned
uh it was horrible and tragic that it
took mr floyd's death to do that but
a wholesale revision of use of force
policies needs to be examined so that
we're dealing humanely
even with people who are criminal
suspects we have a line in this country
beyond which we do not
cross we do not torture people and it is
not the job of the police to try
indict and execute people right on a
public sidewalk
there's a process and that process needs
to be respected
we're looking at it appears to me the
shrine in fact to george floyd outside
where this took place
and um throwing money i'm presuming this
is a reference to the
the so-called counterfeit 20 bill which
led to his original arrest
um there can the city stay calm do you
think tonight
what what is likely to happen now well i
think
given the worldwide outrage
prompted by mr floyd's murder the fact
that
in some ways justice has been delivered
by this
guilty verdict on all counts means that
we'll see more scenes like you're seeing
right now
like your viewers are seeing right now
with relief
and um and joy that the system has
worked
in this instance uh i don't see any
violence
on the streets right now and i certainly
am not seeing that in and around the
community i see people understanding
that the process at least at this
juncture
has delivered justice insofar as we can
give it in this life
and for you will this be a watershed
moment can it be
can this you know rewrite the rules on
racial equality for so many people
we have a long way to go but this is the
first chapter i believe in a new
book and i hope that the message is
heard
throughout the united states throughout
the world
rachel pelosi former u.s attorney for
the district
of minnesota thank you very much indeed
for your time
teaching law now and uh we'll wonder
what the lectures how they'll change
tomorrow after this case certainly
let's speak now to gloria brown marshall
professor brown martial
is a professor of constitutional law at
john jay college of
of criminal justice uh your reaction
then
i was so um nervous
and i've seen a lot in my time being a
civil rights attorney
and researching and writing books on
constitutional law and racial justice
history
and so i was just anxious and um as i
listened to each
verdict i still i i got chills
my reaction is one that this case had
so much weight on it from around the
world the fact
that your listeners and viewers cared
about what went on in in the us with
with this this man
in minneapolis that means a lot to the
african-american community
i'm a scholar but i'm also a human being
and i understand that we've been under
siege for so
long in this country that it was even
this ray of hope of wanting to believe
justice could take place
was sometimes too much to bear because
we've been crushed to the ground so many
times with
philando castile and brianna taylor and
trayvon martin tamir rice and
you just go on and on and on you you
know this so
i'm relieved i know that there's going
to be requests for a mistrial
that you know they want to overturn the
verdict but i'm
hoping that the appellate courts will
see what was done here and that was
justice
well for now certainly derek chovin has
been led away
handcuffed remanded in custody bail
revoked
sentencing due in eight weeks time we
heard that from uh judge peter cahill
the crowds are still there they don't
want to leave do they
we've seen tears hugs chance cheers
applause
no doubt many people doing the same in
their own homes as well watching this
what do you reckon
yes and but i also remember what
happened after joe biden won the
election
very people remember people were in the
streets they were cheering they were
dancing there was music
and then we had the attack on the
capitol by
um these supporters of donald trump
we know that this country is filled with
militia groups
and the the oath keepers and all these
other
like white supremacist organizations um
we're
fearful in a way of what that backlash
is going to be because this nation is so
truly divided
around these these lines that justice
what we believe is justice for george
floyd could be investigation for a civil
war
from these militia groups you don't hope
this will be a healing moment
i know it can be a healing moment for
those of us who are seeking justice
but i also know over a thousand people
are
dying at the hands of police every
police officers more police officers
have to be in those handcuffs they have
to hear the guilty verdict
they have to know that their actions
have consequences
the crux of this case obviously the
video that went around the world that
was filmed
by a 17 year old at the time um
absolutely important evidence no doubt
but how much harder
for george floyd's family did it make
the case having to watch those pictures
again and again
i can tell you i watched the eric garner
strangulation
again and again and again on television
but they only show black people getting
killed
they never show why people get killed
too but at the hands of police they
never show those those are videos as
well
i mean we don't want to become numb to
the harm
that that black people and other people
of color live under by police and by
by white civilians as well so it was
horrible
for all of us we traumatized by that
video
to understand the full extent that this
man could plead not guilty
to putting his knee after the pulse was
gone
um derek shovin still had his knee on on
george floyd's neck
we need to understand it this man
symbolized
a a a a part of this country a cancer
in this country that's what derek chovin
symbolizes so he's not the only one
there are plenty of other derek shovings
around and they're waiting to put their
knee on someone's neck
and hopefully the justice system the
prosecutor's office will step up as they
did here
and prosecute these officers and send
the message that we won't tolerate these
these murders professor what happens now
to
the the other police officers who were
there at the time
i am so glad you asked that question
that has been missed
those other officers can either take a
plea deal
and decide that they're not going to try
to sit and
use the justice system um or they to
decide their fate
they could decide their own fate by
taking a plea deal from the prosecutor's
office
or they're going to decide one of them
just keep this in mind
one of those officers had only been out
of the police academy for 48
hours derek shoving was his training
officer
so derek shoving was training these
young recruits
how to terrorize the black community
so those those young people are going to
have to face trial
they're going to have to decide because
they set back they took an
oath to serve and protect and they said
back and let derek shove and lead them
down a path of folly
that now has given them criminal
consequences
normally at this time gloria we would
take a look at the newspapers here in
the uk
but this is so size makes so historic so
important for the world we'll continue
our coverage of
what has happened in minneapolis uh the
guilty verdicts
for derek chauvin in the death of george
floyd
three guilty verdicts and gloria brown
marshall you're a professor of law
you know how how will the textbooks be
rewritten for this case do you think
it's going to be written written in
three major ways
one is our u.s supreme court has given
this
reasonableness standard and that's why
you heard it in the case
if this had been a civilian on civilian
case once the
evidence presented they would say is
this person guilty or not guilty but
with a police officer
they take the next step and they say oh
um this
this police officer was acting as a
reasonable police officer would
or was this action unreasonable i think
that has been part of the problem
this standard now must be changed also
this sends a message to all police
officers we have 18
000 police jurisdictions in this country
and so it's sending a message to all
police officers
that you too could go to prison for
brutality against civilians
the third thing it does is it supports
national criminal justice reform
because it shows us yes this is
expensive
to have trial by trial but if we change
the law if we put pressure on these
prosecutors offices
to bring more cases then we can have
justice in this country and perhaps
perhaps have the hope you've been
talking about
because people may be able to trust the
police a little bit because right now
there is no trust for police officers
among communities of color
and just one final thought we heard
already from joe biden
the u.s president saying he'd got to
know george floyd's family
he had felt that the case against derek
chauvin was
overwhelming do you feel the door is
open there to
to bring in some of those national
changes that you talked about
i think so because we have a criminal
justice system
that is based on slavery on on slave
catchers
on putting down um the native americans
when they've risen up
we have night riders we have a horrific
history in our policing and they claim
our police departments came from the
bobby system
but actually even that bobby system has
this racial past
so when we're looking at changing we
have to have national reform
because even if we change one part for
example in new york city where i live
but we don't change other cities around
it or other towns then we're going to
end up in another situation
with another george floyd and we cannot
have that as a nation
we have global protests on behalf of
george floyd
but over a thousand people die at the
hands of police every
year we can't have that for every single
case we've got to have
national criminal justice reform and i
think joe biden is willing to support it
and hopefully based on this verdict
we'll have it in the future
yes global protests make it count is
what you're saying isn't it
thank you very much indeed very
interesting to hear your thoughts there
gloria brown marshall
professor of constitutional law at john
jay college of criminal justice as we
heard there
in new york um a statement from mayor
frey
george perry floyd jr came to
minneapolis to better his life
but ultimately his life will have
bettered our city
today the jury joined in a shared
conviction
that has animated minneapolis for the
last 11 months
they refused to look away they believed
their own eyes
and affirmed george floyd should still
be here
today let's go back to solly lockwood
he's down
in the crowds there the crowds still
staying sally still absorbing this news
obviously
absolutely anna this has been a city on
high alert
a state of emergency put in place by the
governor
in anticipation of this verdict and it
has been tense for
weeks now you could feel it around
the city it's even been boarded up to an
extent that it's hard to describe
blocks and blocks and blocks of
buildings completely boarded up here
very militarized downtown in
anticipation
of any unrest but that is far from what
we are seeing let me just give you an
idea people have
spilled out into the streets here around
the courthouse in celebration there are
people
who've stopped their cars in the street
they're beeping their horns they have
flags out
of the sunroof and people are hugging
they're crying it was
an extraordinary moment at the moment
that we received uh that guilty verdict
a short time ago let me just speak to
someone who lives in minneapolis hi
you've
you or you don't live in minneapolis
people here yeah
you're here today where have you come
from i came from
new york but we were here basically
uh to to see how the how the verdict
would go but also
to see how the reaction and the crowd is
and what
are you here from new york i'm more of
an abolitionist
so i believe in more abolishing the
police departments and
more community oriented and you're also
having
something happen right now um
so we're a little
yeah so yeah there's there's a you know
heightened emotions right now we'll show
you some of the scenes that are going on
and thank you for speaking to me
obviously someone standing on a lorry
here oh my goodness
thanks sally apologies if you don't mind
we will just leave that there we've got
a news conference starting let's listen
to that this case began last may
everyone involved has pursued one goal
justice we pursued justice wherever led
when i became the lead prosecutor for
the case i
asked for time and patience to review
the facts
gather evidence and prosecute for the
murder of george floyd to the fullest
extent
the law allowed i want to thank the
community
for giving us that time and allowing us
to do
our work that long hard painstaking work
has culminated today
i would not call today's verdict justice
however
because justice implies true restoration
but it is accountability
which is the first step towards justice
and now the cause of justice
is in your hands and when i say your
hands i mean the hands of the people of
the united states
george floyd mattered he was loved by
his family and his friends
his death shocked the conscience of our
community
our country the whole world
he was loved by his family and friends
but that isn't why
he mattered he mattered because he was a
human being
and there is no way we can turn away
from that reality
the people who stopped and raised their
voices on may 25th
2020 were a bouquet of humanity
a phrase i stole from my friend jerry
blackwell
a bouquet of humanity old young
men and women black and white
a man from the neighborhood just walking
to get a drink
a child going to buy a snack with her
cousin
an off-duty firefighter on her way to a
community garden
brave young women teenagers who press
record on their cell phones
why did they stop they didn't know
george floyd
they didn't know he had a beautiful
family they didn't know
he had been a great athlete and they
didn't know he was a proud
father or that he had people in his life
who
loved him they stopped and raised their
voices
and they even challenged authority
because they saw his
humanity they stopped and they raised
their voices because they knew
that what they were seeing was wrong
they didn't need to be medical
professionals or
experts in the use of force they knew it
was wrong
and they were right these community
members this bouquet of humanity
did it again in this trial
they performed simple yet profound
acts of courage they told the truth
and they told the whole world the truth
about what they saw
they were vindicated by the chief of
police
by minneapolis's longest serving police
officer
and by many other police officers who
stepped up and testified
as to what they saw into what they knew
what happened on that street was wrong
we owe it and we owe our gratitude to
fulfilling their we owe them our
gratitude for fulfilling their civic
duty
and for their courage and telling the
truth to countless people in minnesota
and across the united states who join
them in peacefully demanding justice for
george floyd
we say all of us thank you
in the coming days more may seek to
express themselves again
through petition and demonstration i
urge everyone to honor the legacy of
george floyd
by doing so calmly legally
and peacefully i urge everyone to
continue
the journey to transformation and
justice
it's in your hands now i also want to
address the floyd family if i may
over the last year the family of george
floyd had to relive again
and again the worst day of their lives
when they lost their brother their
father their friend
i'm profoundly grateful to them for
giving us the time we needed
to prosecute this case they have shown
the world what grace
and class and courage really look like
although a verdict alone cannot end
their pain
i hope it's another step on the long
path
toward healing for them there's no
replacing your beloved perry
or floyd as his friends called him
but he is the one who sparked a
worldwide movement
and that's important we owe our thanks
to the men and women
of the jury who gave many hours of their
time and
attention to carefully listening to the
evidence
weighing the facts rendering a verdict
they are regular people from all walks
of life
a lot like that bouquet of comm of
humanity
on that corner on may 25th and in that
courtroom
they answer the call and they served in
a landmark trial
they now deserve to return to their
lives if they ask you to respect their
privacy
we ask you to honor that request
i want to acknowledge the remarkable
team that helped us prosecute the case
we put everything we had into this
prosecution
we presented the best case that we could
and the jury heard us and we're grateful
for that
we had the sole burden of proof in the
case
and history shows that winning cases
like these
can be difficult i'm proud of every hour
every minute and every ounce of effort
we put in this case
and let me tell you we spent many hours
working on this case did we not we week
after week committee meeting after
committee meeting this team
never let up and it never quit we fought
every day
and we did it together the attorney
general's office together with
the hennepin county attorney's office
thank you sir
and we did it together i'm deeply
grateful to everyone who worked on the
case
most of these folks will tell you it's a
bad idea to put together a team of
all michael jordans nobody would want to
pass the ball
this team that was their true strength
is sharing the load passing the ball
understanding that all of us
together are smarter than any one of us
alone
and that works although the verdict
has been rendered this is not the end
in the coming weeks the court will
determine sentencing and later this
summer
we expect to present another case we
will not be talking about that
this verdict reminds us how hard it is
to make enduring change and i just want
to finish by sharing
some important historical legacy if you
allow me
in 1968 the kerner commission was formed
to investigate
the causes of uprisings across major
american cities
and a man named dr kenneth clark a
famous african-american psychologist
who along with his equally accomplished
psychologist wife mamie
contributed to compelling research in
the brown versus board of education case
and dr clark testified at the kerner
commission
and i want to quote you what he said i
read that report the one in the 1919
riot in chicago and it was if i were
reading the report of investigating the
committee
of the harlem riot in 1935
the report on investigating the harlem
riot in 1943
and the report of the macon commission
on the watts riot
i must say again in candor
to you the members of this commission
it's like a
kind of a alice in wonderland with the
same moving picture
re-shown over and over again the same
analysis
the same recommendation and the same in
action those are the words of dr clark
in 1968.
here we are in 1920 excuse me
2020 2021
here we are in 2021 still addressing the
same problem
since dr clark testified we have seen
rodney king admiral ema oscar grant
eric garner michael brown freddie gray
sandra bland
philando castile laquan mcdonald stefan
clark
atiana jefferson anton black brianna
taylor
and now dante wright and adam toledo
this has to end we need
true justice that's not one case
that is a social transformation
that says that nobody's beneath the law
and no one is above it
this verdict reminds us that we must
make
enduring systemic societal change
more than a month ago months before
george floyd was murdered
the minnesota public safety commissioner
john harrington and i
released the recommendations of our
working group on reducing deadly force
encounters with law enforcement
what all of us in that working group
including law enforcement
wanted is for everyone to go home safe
anytime someone doesn't everyone's lives
are changed forever
we need to use this verdict as an
inflection point
what if we just prevented the problem
instead of having to try these cases
we don't want any more community members
dying at the hands
of law enforcement and their families
lives ruined
we want we don't want any more law
enforcement members having to face
criminal charges
in their families lives ruined we don't
want any more communities torn apart
one way to prevent this is to get into a
new relationship
where we as a society re-examine the use
of force
and our old subtle assumptions i'm so
proud of chief aerodondo and the
minneapolis police officers
who by their testimony said enough is
enough
in another way to prevent it is by
acknowledging and lifting up everyone's
humanity
helping communities heal and officers be
well another way to prevent it is with
accountability
passing laws and instituting policies
and training is important
but they must be more than words on
paper and there must be accountability
for violating them with this verdict we
have brought some accountability
finally this verdict demands us to never
give up the hope
that we can make enduring change
generations of people said slavery would
never end
generations said jim crow would never
end generations said women would never
be equal to men
generation said if you were different in
any way you could never be a full
and equal member of our society today
we have to end this travesty of
recurring
endurant enduring deaths at the hands of
law enforcement
those beliefs
are things we have to focus our
attention on and as i now do close
i just want to say to you the work of
our generation is to put
unaccountable law enforcement behind us
it's time to transfer the relationship
transform the relationship
between community and the people who are
sworn uh
to protect them from one that is
mistrustful suspicious
and in some cases terrifying into one
that is
empathetic compassionate and affirming
with that benefit that will benefit
everyone including police officers
who deserve to serve in a profession
that is honored
in departments where they don't have to
worry about
colleagues who don't follow the rules
now the word that work is in your hands
the work of our generation is to put an
end to the vestiges
of jim crow in the centuries of trauma
and finally put an end
to racism we can end it it doesn't have
to be with us
into the future if we decide now
to have true liberty and justice for all
the work of our generation is to say
goodbye to old practices
that don't serve us anymore and to put
them all behind us
one conviction even one like this one
that creates
even one like this one can create a
powerful new opening to shed old
practices
and reset relationships
so with that i just want to say that
i do hope that people step forward and
understand that
nobody can do everything but everybody
can do something you can do something
the way like everyday people like donald
williams and geneva
genevieve hansen and christopher martin
and charles mcmillan and all those
teenagers and young people
stepped up and did something you can do
things like
help pass the george floyd
justice and accountability act it's in
your hands
let's get the work done and now i'd like
to invite my friend
and partner in justice michael freeman
hennepin county attorney
thank you mr attorney general well
there's uh there's a lot of news
conferences coming up i just want to
tell you about some more
that was the minnesota attorney general
keith ellison i'll return to his
comments in a moment
uh but just to say that joe biden and
vice president kamala harris
are expected to deliver remarks on the
verdict
in the derek chauvin trial later on this
evening that's according to the white
house
we're also expecting to hear from george
floyd's family the civil rights attorney
ben crump
will be joined by the family of george
floyd as well
to give their news today let's just
listen
from outside the court there we don't
have justice until we get
educational justice for people of color
in this country
but today we are moving forward and
minnesotans
god chose us let's carry on this burden
let's
shine a little bit of a light a north
star
light for the rest of this country that
we shine a light of
justice for this country and we lit this
guilty verdict flow on the mississippi
river
all the way down to delta to allow this
country
to taste what it's like for a little bit
of victory
a little bit of victory and with that i
say
with that i say we thank god almighty we
thank god almighty
we thank god almighty but guess what we
are not done
right if you think we're going home
we're not going home three more officers
have killed george floyd
they we need justice from them and dante
wright
was killed in the middle of this trial
to
show us that the justice system in this
country
and accountability has yet to be had and
we
will demand justice by any
means
one down three to go one down
three to go one down we're gonna go
one down three to go one down three to
go
one down three to go
one down four more to go four more to go
and next i'd like to go ahead and
introduce
the founder and the president of
families supporting families
against police brutality
yes garroway
yeah we love you we love you
i am horse go ahead because i have been
out here
for over a year
yelling for justice for all stolen lives
and i want to say
that when justin tugging was beat to
death and thrown in a dumpster
11 years ago i knew that there would be
more
and may 25th 2020 that
more came because god told me it was
going to start coming out
and it came out last year and i've been
out here fighting with my boots on the
ground
and i've been yelling to the rooftops
but i've been yelling up to god and
today he let rain
justice rain down upon us the flying
gates of heaven is open up right now
and we got the justice that we deserve
and i will not stop
fighting they say we got fomo to go uh
um we got a lot we got
hundreds more to go there's over 470
bodies
in the state of minnesota in the last 20
years
that have led up to george floyd so that
means we got over 470 more
offices to go we want them off the
streets
we want them out of our communities we
want those
officers that allow ordeal surreal to
die in that
jail we want them out of the jails
that's the correction
all of them that have no value for the
black men
yes 32 years
well with apologies to to shira garaway
there let's now listen to
the prosecutor practice with this
incredible
gifted trial team and so i stand here
today
in gratitude i'm thankful
i want to thank the jury for their
service for doing what was right
and decent and correct and speaking the
truth
and finding the right verdict in this
case
i'm jerry blackwell and my comments are
going to be
fairly brief i want to first say thank
you
to all of these selfless servants that
you see standing here and the many more
that you do not see
who had the willingness the courage the
passion
the intestinal fortitude to get into
good trouble
they stepped into the light and they
shine
and for that i say thank you i'm
grateful for them i'm grateful for the
opportunity
that i've had to serve now no verdict
can bring george perry floyd back to us
but this verdict does give a message to
his family
that he was somebody that his life
mattered
that all of our lives matter and that's
important
and i also hope that this verdict for
all of the rest of collective all of us
will help us further along the road
toward a better humanity
thank you all i'm matt frank
well i can't really follow that too much
but i just want to say that
it's been really a privilege to work
with this awesome group of dedicated
hard-working
uh people in this endeavor
but it's also been a just a total
privilege to get to know the floyd
family
and spend time with them and get to know
them
because first and foremost this is for
you george floyd
and for your family and friends thank
you
thank you
so let me also think very publicly aaron
eldridge who was part of our trial team
who's not here today
but was indispensable lola velasquez
agaloo thank you lola for a wonderful
job that you did
josh larson josh thanks so much my
friend
uh zuri balma kung thank you zuri
and natasha robinson i want to thank you
and your the next generation
the next generation of justice seekers
dion dodd i want to thank you
dionne where are you thank you very much
and i want to thank you vernon boswell
you are a star uh and i also want to
thank so many other people
but for with that we're going to close
our comments right now
and just say that uh we're prepared to
continue to pursue justice
thank you mr ellison what kind of
sentence are you going to see
so that was the minnesota attorney
general keith ellison
introducing to the prosecuting team
steve schleicher
jerry blackwell who reminded people that
he was somebody his life
mattered and matthew frank two who in
tears said
this is for you george and for your
family and your friends the prosecuting
team
clearly emotional after the verdicts
today
we've heard that the president and vice
president watched the verdict with staff
in the private dining room of the white
house
and following the announcement of the
verdict the president spoke
to governor tim waltz the president the
vice president and the first lady
then spoke to philanese floyd from the
oval office that's the brother of george
floyd
she has been you know marcia yeah she's
the head honcho out here since this all
happened we the jury in the above
entitled matter as to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
joven the ex-police officer who killed
george floyd
is convicted of murder and manslaughter
[Music]
[Applause]
the verdict has prompted tears and
jubilation
on the streets of minneapolis with
george floyd's family describing the
result
as painfully earned justice
president biden will deliver remarks on
the verdict later we'll be live
in minneapolis for the latest reaction
so let's bring you the breaking news of
this evening then the former police
officer
derek chauvin has been convicted of
murder and manslaughter
over the death of george floyd mr floyd
died
last may after officer chauvin pinned
his knee
on his neck for around nine and a half
minutes during an arrest
where the killing as you remember
sparked nationwide protests
today a jury in minneapolis reached its
verdict after
10 hours of deliberation stretched over
two days
here is the moment then that judge peter
cahill read out the verdicts to the
court in minneapolis
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court fourth judicial district
state of minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
verdict
count one court file number 27 cr200
we the jury in the above entitled matter
as to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 44 pm signed juror 4 person
juror number 19.
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter has to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19 same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter has to count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm
well enormous reactions you can imagine
outside we're expecting news conferences
from the legal team for george floyd and
his family as well
already as you can see people have
gathered they're not leaving
there were tears there were hugs there
were chance there was clapping
there was applause absolute astonishment
really
this unusual result it is more often the
case that the police officer does not
uh get found guilty of charges like this
let's bring in
greg milam and certainly there's a sense
isn't there for many people there greg
that this is indeed a seismic moment in
in in in racial equality for america
yeah it is i think for this city that's
been through so much uh since may last
year
uh a real sense of relief a real sense
of healing as we've heard from a number
of the people who've come down here and
the massive reaction in this city to
that uh verdict
is is very very palpable uh in contrast
i think to what we saw in the court and
you saw it there the reaction
or no reaction from derek chovin himself
maybe his eyes flicking towards the jury
uh his face hidden by the mask of course
as those verdicts were
were read out and a pretty quick
decision by this jury just over 10 hours
of deliberation
after a three-week trial would suggest
that as the prosecution said to them in
closing yesterday
they could believe their eyes that what
they saw on that video that we all saw
was simply what they saw
and that any uh defense argument was was
nothing beyond
uh nonsense the judge peter cahill
thanked the jury for what he says was
heavy duty
jury service and i think everybody could
agree with that uh derek chauvin
will come back to the court in in eight
weeks time to be sentenced the
maximum sentence according to minnesota
law for that that most serious charge is
40 years
the feeling is for someone without a
criminal conviction before this
like him that it would be a maximum of
12 years but
uh the prosecutors are likely uh to seek
more
and then we saw that moment that will i
think for a lot of those watching what
happened today will be very significant
derek chauvin
his hands pulled behind his back
handcuffed and taken away
into custody to await that sentencing
you can see there
some of those including the reverend al
sharpton who have been part of the
family support network
have spoken on a number of days um
during this trial about the
what the family have been through and
what this trial means
we'll also tonight hear from joe biden
the president who we know has called the
uh
the floyd family their lawyer has posted
some video of
of that moment the president talking to
to ben crump let's listen to al sharpton
when ben crump called
we remembered how eric garner
said i can't breathe 11 times his mother
came with us to the site
the family came in and this family has
stood together
for the last 11 months
watching this video go
over and over and over again this family
stood with pain
suffering and not knowing what the
future held
because so many families went and got
nothing
they thanked god when they got the
indictment which would not have happened
had not the attorney general keith
ellison took this case
and keith ellison fought and put
together a team
that made this possible and this is the
first time in the history of this state
that a white police officer has been
convicted
less known convicted of a murder
this is the first time in a long raid of
fights
that we've seen three counts
guilty at all three we don't
find pleasure in this we don't celebrate
a man going to jail
we would have rather george be alive
amen
but we celebrate that we
because young people white and black
some castigated many that are here
tonight marched
and kept marching yeah and kept going
many of them looked down on but they
kept marching
and wouldn't let this die and this is
an assurance to them that if we don't
give up
that we can win some rounds but the war
and the fight is not over just two days
from now
we're going to have to deal with the
funeral
of dante wright in this same
county the same area we still have
cases to fight but this gives us the
energy to fight on
and we are determined that we gonna
fight until we make
federal law yes the george floyd
justice and policing act must be long
we want to thank all that were involved
especially the attorney general and the
governor
and others we want to thank president
biden
who the first time he came out of his
house
during the campaign he flew to houston
and met with the family and attorney
crump and i
and he sat there and i will never forget
he's he said to
george's daughter that i heard you say
your father
is gonna change the world well we can
now tell george's daughter she was right
her father has began the changing of the
world for real but before we do anything
we first want to pray there you go and
thank god
because somehow god made a way he had
mercy
we believe in a god that can even get
through the cracks in the jury room
and bring conscious and bring truth
and that jury we want to thank them for
letting god
give them the strength wherever they are
tonight
we want them to know we broke down in
tears
when we heard the verdict we had to hold
each other and hug in tears
because too many nights we've cried many
of us for decades
spent nights in jail but today we can
wipe our tears away
and fight on for another day there's
sunlight
we're going to keep going till we bring
it for the eriganders and the brianna
taylor whose boyfriend is here tonight
kenny walker sean bell
so many that did not get this night this
night is for them let us pray
let's lock arms and pray like we can
folks
where come on brandon where's for london
yeah come on you and rodney come up
front you know he's hiding now
brother chris get your next
attorney general there let's pray
dear god we thank you for giving us the
strength to stand together
sometimes we would question each other
sometimes we say this is just going to
be a waste of time
but somehow you touch us in the midnight
hours
and teach us to hold on and that if we
would be
faithful over a few things you'd give us
the victory over many
we thank you because we know it was not
any doing of
ours but your loving kindness and your
tender mercy
it made tonight possible bless those
that worked that made this prosecution
something they couldn't deny bless those
policemen
they got on the stand and testified
against another policeman
bless the jury that listened to the
evidence and didn't listen to those
that may criticize them for doing this
bless the prosecutor keith ellison
and his staff yes they did their job
even though they didn't know what the
outcome would be
bless ben crump in a special way that
worked tirelessly that jumped
on planes and left his family to make
sure that justice would rain down
thank you for all of the civil and human
rights leaders that stood up
and we thank you for the nameless
grandmas and grandpas
that would get on their knees and ask
you to give us a victory this time
and lord as we give you the thanks
and give you the praise let george know
that his name is going down in history
they may have put their knee on his neck
but he will now be a figure
that we will take the knees off our
necks now
and we give you the praise thank you
and god we give you the glory these
blessings we ask in your name
amen amen amen
me say that i want to bring on now
a man who has symbolized the fight
for justice he didn't seek the role
but he rose to the occasion america
for many years didn't have someone to
stand for us
the last four years we didn't have an
attorney general's office that would
even hear outcry
but we had been raised to believe that
god always has a ram in the bush
and god has a way of taking the most
humble of people
and raising numbers up we had an
attorney general in black america
that has represented these cases with
the acumen and skill
of one that was raised in the south but
came to claim this nation in a new
direction
i bring you the attorney general for
black america
ben crump i love it
thank you reverend al sharpton not only
for
your mentorship not only for being a
great civil rights leader but for being
a moral authority
especially making sure no matter what
happened
that we always maintained the moral high
ground
knowing that we were on the right side
of history as we fought for justice
for george perry floyd jr
say his name
i am uh but a member of a great team
of very talented attorneys
and i'm going to acknowledge them yeah
we got the omegas and the kappas
reverend jackson
and the alphas in it that's right
i oh to acknowledge these great group of
lawyers and then the family members
uh two or three of the lawyers will
address you
and then at that time we will hear from
the family members before we take any of
your questions
i want to acknowledge
a great lawyer from chicago illinois
one of the best i've ever had a chance
to work with attorney tony romanucci
i want to recognize my partner on the
front line
in this case one of the best lawyers
and ben own them uh he hails from
atlanta georgia attorney chris stewart
his law partner attorney justin miller
attorney madeline simmons
uh a great minnesota lawyers
attorney jeff storms raise your hand
yeah
attorney michelle goodell
and who else we got here anybody else
attorneys we have attorney scott
masterson who's not present uh
attorney pavani i i said michelle we got
michelle
all right uh it's just a great group of
lawyers
and i want to let you know who we have
present here with the family
here in minneapolis for this historic
day
we have uh george floyd's brothers
we have philonous floyd
we have rodney floyd we have
brandon williams who's george floyd's
nephew
but was more like a son to him they call
him wu back in the third ward
we have keita floyd for lotus his wife
we have oh where's that new york way yet
[Music]
we got terence floyd um his sisters who
are not with us but
we should absolutely acknowledge uh
bridget floyd who hails from north
carolina
his sisters latonya and zsa
who hail from houston texas we have his
cousins uh sharita mcgee
tdr mcgee and tara brown
and we have uh the mother of his
daughter
gianni floyd we have roxy washington and
we have gianna
[Applause]
and so uh i'll make
some brief remarks and then we're going
to have attorney stuart
oh
[Music]
angela cousin paris and his uncle
i know it's a big crew
[Music]
a.d
the man he came to minneapolis with
anna darrell so i'll make some brief
remarks and then we're going to
have attorney steward and attorney ramon
lucci make some brief remarks
and then we're going to hear from this
family
and we're going to try to
leave here today knowing that america is
a better country
america let's
pause for a moment
to proclaim this historical moment
not just for the legacy of george floyd
but for the legacy of america
the legacy of trying to
make america for all americans
so that george floyd's victory
and america's quest
for equal justice under the law will be
intertwined
america let's frame this moment
as a moment where we finally
are getting close to living up to our
declaration of independence
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all men are created equally that
they're endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights that
amongst them are life
in liberty in the pursuit of happiness
where america that means all of us
that means black people that means
hispanic people
that means native people that means
asian people
that means all of us america we frame
this moment
for all of us not just for george floyd
this is a victory
for those who champion humanity over
inhumanity
those who champion justice over
injustice
those who champion morals over
immorality america
let's lean into this moment
and let's make sure forever now that
this moment
will be documented
for our children get them born
as they continue on the journey to
justice
knowing that the blood of george floyd
will give them a trail to find a way to
a better america a more just america
a more just america where briana taylor
gives an opportunity to
sleep in peace at night without the
police busting in her front door
a more just america where mod aubry gets
to run
free and not be lynched for jogging
while black
or more just where jacob blake
and anthony mclean and walter scott
and laquan mcdonald and all these other
black men
terence crutcher who was shot in the
back
while running away like dante wright was
just a week ago because for some reason
black men running away from the police
is more dangerous
than young white men who commit mass
murders
and walk towards the police with an
assault
weapon reverend like kyle
rittenhouse in kenosha wisconsin
america let this be the precedent yes
let this be the precedent where we
live up to the high ideals and the
promises when we say
liberty and justice for all
those sunkissed children
are included in all
those children who overcame slavery
the middle passage the dress scott
decision
classified ferguson jim crow
and his much smarter wiser son jim crow
junior
esquire let this be the precedence
where we overcome systematic racism and
oppression
and that we are a better people
and we will leave our children
a better world a better world for us all
at this time we will hear from
a great lawyer because
nobody does this alone it's always a
team effort
and we have the lawyers the preachers
the civil rights leaders the education
leaders
the activists yes let's give a big round
of applause
for the activists yeah that's right the
people who stayed in the streets
right the people who came nationally
but more importantly the people who were
here locally
who were standing up for joshua on 38th
in chicago avenue
day in and day out silky the people who
win
go home wednesday quiet reverend jackson
people followed
y'all example don't forget about the
witnesses
to be here
[Applause]
well celebration as you can see there
from ben crump
uh who's been acting as the family
lawyer surrounded by
many members of uh george floyd's family
civil rights leaders too you saw the
reverend al
sharpton there in tears so many families
went and got
nothing he said i'm gonna dip out of
this just briefly because already
uh ben crump has thanked president biden
and vice president kamala harris for the
a call to the floyd family let's just
listen to it
hello hey
and you know i think uh i think if john
is coming my dad is going to change the
world he's going to start to change it
now
that's right yes
you've been incredible you're an
incredible thing i wish i were there
just before arms around you
i'm standing here cedric we've been
talking and we're watching every second
of this and
the vice president all of us and uh
i'm just i we're all so relieved
and uh yes it's really important i'm
anxious to see you guys
i really am and we're gonna get a lot
more done we're gonna get police we're
gonna do
a lot we're gonna stay at it till we get
it done
hopefully this is the momentum for the
george floyd justice and policing act
to get past to have you signed got it
thank you mr president well this can be
our first shot at dealing with
genuine systemic racism
people here that feel strongly vice
president she wants to say something
[Music]
okay thankful
for the entire family your courage has
been a strength
[Music]
and in georgia's name and memory we are
going to make sure his legacy is intact
and that history will look back at this
moment and know that it's
the reflection moment you have to
sacrifice so much your family did too
but we really do believe that with your
leadership and
and the president that we have in the
white house
that we're gonna make something good
come out of this tragedy
because when we do it we're going to put
you on airforce
we're going to hold you to that
president jesus gary
thank you mr president recall in the
moments
after the verdict then the president and
the vice president calling ben crump and
members of the
floyd family we heard from kamala harris
there will make something good come out
of this tragedy
and joe biden himself telling the family
nothing is going to make it all better
but at least now there is some justice
we're all so relieved and uh they had
both been watching from the private
dining room
just off the oval office watching those
live pictures of the
of the courtroom and we are expecting
them to give a news conference as well
this evening
to give their reaction to that news so
stand by for that
barack obama former us president has
also tweeted
today a jury did the right thing but
true justice requires
much more michelle and i send our
prayers to the floyd family
and we stand with all those who are
committed to guaranteeing
every american the full measure of
justice
that george and so many others have been
denied the words there are barack obama
tonight
bruce johnson has also tweeted this
evening i was appalled by the death of
george floyd
and welcomed this verdict my thoughts
tonight are with george floyd's family
and friends the words there of the uk
prime minister
um other breaking news tonight you may
have seen on our straps and elsewhere
that all six english football clubs who
initially said that they were taking
part in the
controversial european super league are
now withdrawing
their involvement from the breakaway
tournament it began
with the news that chelsea suggested
that they were
confirming their intention to pull away
then manchester city
now all six of those clubs have decided
to pull out
of the european super league let's get
the very latest now from martha kelman
it was a plot which completely
disregarded them
but as the european super league comes
tumbling down
here they are
the fans united defiant and ultimately
successful
in heralding the end of the most
unpopular plan in football history
as their supporters protested outside
the stadium urging owner roman
abramovich to reconsider
chelsea were preparing documents to
formally withdraw from the league
they should have done it in the first
place i don't know why they thought it'd
be a good idea
but after seeing this well they had no
choice did they really
i'm glad that um we've all come down
here and made our voices heard tonight
because we haven't been able to do that
for over a year now so
no i'm i'm pleased that we're out of it
but it should never happen in the first
place
from what i've heard roman wasn't keen
on it anyway so i think it was
it was at the back of his mind whether
he was gonna go forward with it or not
but i think it's definitely
it's definitely put the the fans voice
to the sort of forefront of the
talk i think so happy days really this
is the man who schemed in the background
to orchestrate the 12 team breakaway
ed woodward resigned as vice chairman of
manchester united tonight
after a nine-year reign many will
conclude the chaotic
failure of this attempted super league
is behind the sudden announcement of his
departure
manchester city soon followed chelsea by
informing the super league of their
intention to pull out
leaving the whole project surely doomed
their manager one of football's most
renowned
had already expressed his disgust at a
closed league
is not a sport when the relation between
the effort and the success the effort
and reward
doesn't exist don't exist so it's not a
sport
so it's not a sport of the success is
already guaranteed
it's not a sport and it doesn't matter
if you lose
the uefa president alexander chefferin
said
i'm delighted to welcome city back to
the european football family
it takes courage to admit a mistake but
i have never doubted that they had the
ability and common sense to make that
decision
city are a real asset for the game
and the prime minister promised
government would land a legislative form
on the six rebel clubs
to ensure they couldn't break away how
can it be right to have a situation in
which you create a kind of
uh cartel that stops uh clubs competing
against each other
playing against each other we will seek
a legislative solution
uh but we hope that uh they can find a
way forward
themselves the super league were
insisting just hours ago that all
12 clubs were equally committed that
there were no cracks
but perhaps this level of fan opposition
there are hundreds of fans here closing
a busy london
thoroughfare was enough to turn the tide
the players too had made their
opposition known
most were blindsided by the super league
plan and many felt hung out to drive by
their owners
liverpool captain jordan henderson
convening a meeting of premier league
captains
marcus rashford who has become a force
for social good tweeted
quoting manchester united legend matt
busby as bruce buck's side played
brighton this evening
the chelsea chairman seemed distracted
[Applause]
his club didn't drive this league they
were the first of the 12 to pull out
but like the rest they have dealt a
massive self-inflicted blow to their
reputation
martha kellner sky news stamford bridge
well two monumental pieces of breaking
news tonight which will be reflected in
the newspapers
the guilty verdict for derek chauvin in
the case of george floyd
a story we've been covering all evening
and the news there
as many of the newspapers will be
reporting uh that the european super
league all six english clubs have now
decided to pull out reflecting on those
big stories tonight i'll be joined and
i'll look at the newspapers by the
observers chief leader writer sonia
soder
and the columnist for the article ali
mirage and continuing coverage too
from minneapolis tonight in the case of
george floyd back in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you